Cambridge Angels started back in about 2001.
Those of you with long memories will remember this wasn't exactly the best time to start...
...because shortly after that everything collapsed.
But, there was a small group of people in Cambridge...
...who had all made a reasonable amount of money by starting and selling companies.
And that was enough to start a small group together,...
...probably only about 12 or 15 in the first meeting,...
...who then managed to get people coming to them with lots of ideas.
And gradually over the next three or four years,...
...Cambridge Angels became quite an interesting and important organisation.
We have grown from those initial dozen or so people to around about 45.
We invest something between two and three million pounds per year.
And at the moment we have two very large deals going on,...
...which together amount to nearly two million pounds of investment.